okay so this is forget the name ghost
princess okay this is surprisingly about
a living Prince and this is a Finn and
Jake they're sitting around a fire and
this ghost princess comes in trying to
haunt them and she said they can't she
can't not haunt until she figures out
how she died and cuz she's she's in the
50 stage of death or needs to go on to
the 50s today fifty second dead world
fifty second is that fifty second or
fifty seven
I think he's fifty second dead world
yeah okay and one of those worlds and
she has to find out she dies as you move
on to the next one so Finn that Jake a
but waited solve so they put her with
this other guy Clarence and say yeah
just stick with him while we figure out
how you died and it turns out he was one
that killed her but they had a romance
before death and now after death and by
the way big spoiler alert Jesus he
bought the mystery didn't have to give
away the yeah that's what we do oh we do
that like watching the commentary I'm
like you know no don't tell them that
will ruin it you're watching my
commentary season commentaries do enjoy
weird Oh but okay so you got them so she
ascends but then Jake helps Clarence
realized how he died and then he ascends
and they fall in love again and they
live happily ever after because Jake can
now eat processed cheese once more and
yeah that's about the end of it and I
liked it I thought it was funny I
actually really want to know more about
that backstory that they had the when
she was warrior princess and he was
whatever he was just the rulers of land
or something and like it looks
legitimately epic it's like we saw the
ending of this really epic story that
even sir continued on into the ghost
world and it's like wow like what led to
this what led to them like falling in
love but then building their countries
then he felt he had to take over and she
had
fender land and they had to find a nice
dancer and he's like cry all over and
say it's both hilarious and really epic
oh and I actually look jamia we want to
know more about this my wife is
shaking my nuts that sounds worse she
should know those are my nuts oh she's
shaking there's no way to not make this
sound bad so bottom line she's shaking
the nuts for the cat Naruto yep no way
to make this not sound bad so don't do
that
the cats just can't stay there by the
way just to go back no let's keep
talking about waving our nuts for the
cat I know way of my nuts for the cat I
don't know what your hands yet by the
way the tanks were fun it was great yeah
until he ran over the fence yeah but
wasn't ours who cares oh good point no
going back kind of to that I love how
you're not concerned with the backstory
like that's not even on your mind of the
backstory with the Ice King you're like
more interested in there you go
the mint ugh
no yeah that's right I remember whose
thoughts I'm gonna kill you in your
sleep get to Jurgis Lee beat you at
tanks this time no he's kicking the
glasses you were just more concerned
with the glasses than his back story but
this one you're totally the backstory
was incredible we talked about it but
that's the thing we talked about just
because we disagree we both agreed the
back story was incredible for the ice
skating sounds like the best payoff of
anything ever oh man what caused the war
well cuz the actual mystery itself
wasn't that much of mystery and it's a
touch obvious fun right but no either
way it sounds weird but even like just
the short kind of goofy love that goes
princess and Clarence shared like it's
even that short amount of time you still
kind of buy it to like know there's
sappy and goofy but it kind of works you
just get the feeling like she's like the
you know been wandering just going to
people ah you know not knowing what to
do I just go uh-huh and then here's this
guy it's just like you know hey no it's
good I'm not to do I gotta bought it
strangely enough
remember that's also one of the
princesses that Ice King does not like
because you can't touch her with her
love mitts with his love mitts
I do love when the three bad ghosts
clinical bed ghosts show up and they're
about to beat up Finn Jake because you
know of course Finn was bad cop but
they're about you and uh Clarence and
ghost princess show up it's like hey
they're with me and he's like okay
I'll do this because that one time it
did that one thing and you were cool how
can a ghost even do that be
controversial like they do they don't
want people to know about who whatever
even that like actually my wife while
watching was like you know let's go to a
place where we can be more private and
like ghosts make love like did they get
pregnant do they give birth to ghost
babies how is that possible they're dead
will your friends align with their death
either go sperm did the closed I do I
raise that question ghosts and I've
never got an answer why did he pointier
I said brings up a good question that
I've always had so vampires they have no
reflection but neither do their clothes
for some reason so if they're in a full
suit of body like of armor like a knight
will that show up in the mirror we're
just blowing the lid
all these famous mythologies and how
they're really stupid yeah yeah but
according to this yes their clothes do
die okay ah because you saw when they
die their clothes went up with them yeah
apparently so that's nice yeah just
don't need a lot of cheese all at once
you'll blow up apparently that is a
hilarious death but I thought that was I
love that Lee just mix it like kind of
this these really sad moments with
really funny moments on top of him like
when he what he friggin stabs her with
just like holy crap and then but he's
like crying over here is Boca
heartbreaking is hilarious at the same
time I found it incredibly disgusting
and ugly for Jory to sit there go Oh God
cuz that she's crying she's like this ya
know how's that you comment prints up
they could both keep it kind of hard so
ya know I liked it anything else you got
I think you raised a lot of good
questions though can closed I yeah and
your wife also raised good questions to
ghost babies well actually if you know
the thing about pac-man the cartoon
there was pac-man jr. yeah yeah this is
really stupid
no I need to do research now ya know
there are kid ghosts they actually grow
up to what was that movie we saw with
the abortion well the abortion that was
haunting them oh my god it was that
Indian one we watched some Indian movie
where this lady got an abortion and and
I ended up haunting and like the couple
so yes
their other daughters that they kept and
then the baby was growing up because
they were too busy with
with their careers I you not
they're too busy but then they had ass
like a kid a second kid this time they
had had the kid and yes the boarded baby
who came back we're stopping now